[Music]
that's the wrong song know what what
guys screw up we're not starting this
acapella group Wonderwoman 1984 trailer
is here it was the first time the four
of us are in a video together yeah let
the out shadowing begin the first time I
saw Wonder Woman was actually with this
exact group right here so I said hey we
gotta watch the trailer together and
recording in the house say what's up
what's up guys in a suit don't ask why
Olivia
say what's up what's up that's right
John hi I'm John what's up I think the
first time we got in a fight actually
right when this movie was done Andrews
first instinct was to be cool movie guy
and start criticizing the film right
away and then I was like do do do do do
did you're like shut up you're pissing
me off and then you walked out of the
theater so thanks Andrew yeah my bag
sorry I didn't mean to get in the way of
a scuffle between you two my bed why are
we making this about this guys Andrew
gave us some presents right here thank
you Andrew
welcome my pleasure Gary Christmas you
and your friends with me you get
presents guys now we're all very true
well make sure to subscribe and click
that notification bell if you end up
liking this video let's see how this
goes
they're gonna show Bruce Wayne's picture
when she said it love this stranger
things court my captor is this yield she
was thinking about Steve
I think in return
[Music]
Oh
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah it's like the
Justice League didn't love the look at
this nice look it's more backstory back
to femme askew Wow where's cheetah like
The Dark Knight truck flips over
the doors in this
Wow oh wow that looks awesome man
the action looks great and well Paige
eggs has got a record a lot saying guys
Steve Trevor is not being shoehorn into
this he's gonna naturally fit into the
plot from there's like things I've heard
circulating I mean it's cool to see
Pedro Pascal in here who's like an actor
who's just seems to be getting more and
more work and he's gonna be like a
superstar sooner or later I'm excited to
see him playing Maxwell Lord and I've
heard some stuff potentially that he is
like looking for an artifact and that is
what he you know he like enlist the help
of Diana and in order to get Diana's
help he resurrects Steve Trevor back to
life that's like one of those looks here
so he's as smart as Enchantress where
she like breaks it open then turns of
potential but they make it look like
Maxwell Lord is more of the primary
villain here and is interesting that
they've been talking so much in the
promo leading up to this that cheetah is
the main villain but she looked more
like a cool supporting character here
we're best buds until something goes
wrong yeah you don't see that you don't
see the cheetah character but the end is
right here that's why but the action was
this looks like a completely different
kind of movie which I'm excited about I
don't want I don't want them to try to
do you know like how do we top the
no-man's lion scene or how do we
communicate the exact same emotion from
the last one I feel like the tones gonna
be very different the action imaginably
like for patty Jenkins first action
movie to be Wonder Woman and how great
that look there I can only imagine how
much better it's gonna look here like
there's a lot of CGI because a lot of
in-camera stunt work that we're seeing
here I'm just super excited about it go
Andrew we need more slow motion action
shots we didn't get enough in the
but my real question in this trailer was
was Maxwell Lord holding baby Yoda
couldn't tell me where's baby Yoda okay
just like I couldn't get it no but
seriously when aunt you found out Pedro
Pascal is masculine changed my life fell
better he's like what every joke baby
fever right now seriously I love the 80s
look at this I love the music the look
the style I mean it's just unbelievable
I mean I was an 80s boy but I guess you
call me more of a 90s buggers as part of
a to eat end of the 80s but this is so
cool it really has that flavor and
feeling the action just looks amazing
and I really love how were how Barbara
Minerva and Diana are friends like that
and then lick the inner the awkward
interaction there ya know is there's
like classic Kristen Wiig but you can
tell she's really gonna change as a
character throughout when she starts
like you know getting her powers and
stuff and she really seems like and
again we haven't really seen anything
but I'm really looking forward to seeing
her as like an actual physical threat as
well as a psychological threat to Diane
because they're friends like that kind
of gets you a little bit so I mean Greg
and I fight all the time so like we can
relate to that all as big time so it's
gonna be interesting to see our life
story played out by two women yeah
definitely and let the woman sweet now
women are bad talk I think Wonder Woman
is single-handedly the most important
female superhero of all time and seeing
Wonder Woman one we got that huge no
man's land scene I think they could
recreate it in a different way in this
movie just because that's how powerful
Wonder Woman is and and her influence on
females all over the world
um so I'm excited to see what they will
come up with in this movie I'm also
happy we didn't get to see cheetah a lot
um I'm glad they're keeping that kind of
under wraps because I don't want
everything spoiled for me and I'm hoping
that he's pull and he's pulling the
strings like making sure to do what she
does like from a psychological level and
I'd be interesting from my understanding
seems like Maxwell like you got that you
kind of got this Lex Luthor kind of
presence with Maxwell Lord who has this
terrible ability and then you have the
bar
Nerva character who's a lot more
intelligent in her home ways being an
archeology we just tell everyone that
I'm dressed as Max well sure why not
Shawn has to talk Andrew Olivia sorry
dude John no I mean I like the
difference in setting I mean I like the
80s aesthetics and stuff like that and
just hearing what patty Jenkins was
talking about and gal gadot about how
they did all these practical stunts and
effects and stuff like that and didn't
rely heavily on the CG I thought that
was cool I love that we don't get to see
cheetah and you know you see the Pedro
Pascal influence over what's going on
here the Maxwell Lord stuff I have a
feeling that's gonna lead to a lot of
drama she's probably gonna have to learn
to let go of Steve by the end is my
guess because she's gonna get him back
in a sinister way and then you know he's
gonna come in between her and her best
friends so it looks like this is going
to be very personal movie for Diana
where's the first one was about learning
more about the world the human world
especially and I don't know this one
yeah just looks like a more Diana based
character you're right you added on
nothing John why one question two is
Pedro Pascal really in his suitors ever
I don't know a Mandalorian like that you
tell anyone also that that mascara like
gladiator yeah they look like they were
having some type of exhibition show or
some type of competition show there that
looked awesome oh it's great yeah
Barbara Minerva off camera ultimately is
what shapes and transforms her Superman
like wanting to stay away from humans
correct I think so yeah oh yeah most of
that was read condo like this stuff in
Batman V Superman who cares all right
guys what did you think of the Wonder
Woman 1984 trailer got any theories do
you think it'll be better than Wonder
Woman one do you think it'll be better
than Joker
haha let's compare they're both in the
80s the co2 thor ragnarok or at least
color aesthetically it has to be the
same movie
has made that joke six times in the last
seven seven seven times get the number
right okay make sure to subscribe to the
rail rejects click that notification
melih get notified whenever we got a
YouTube video thank you Andrew again for
these gifts well I'd like to end this
with a patron the day shout out to all
the men at our patron our patient of the
day shout out a woman named Jen Smith
Jen haven't heard from you in quite a
while actually I've talked about Olivia
quite a bit to her because Jen has
someone in her family with autism and
Olivia works with autistic children and
I don't know where I'm going with this
now that I said it I was just kind of
communicating facts here and I thought
there might be some type of sincere
thing I can go with and now I feel like
I've just entered some uncomfortable
territory this is why she goes did you
this is why she goes to two knees I made
you singular and Me's blur next
president I get you a yarmulke Greg
Andres Jewish so it's okay we make that
choice right I'm one of the chosen ones
I don't know where I'm going with this
Jen this is supposed to be about you i
jen i love you and miss you
olivia any work the wisdom you want to
share now that I brought up this
connecting fact between you two you
probably message you probably need to
know the specifics don't you message her
this went great